Two videos ago, I told you that
when you're dealing with
an exponential function, that
when you increase x by a
constant amount that the y
values will increase by a
constant factor.
When we increased x from
0 to 1, we increased y
by a factor of 1.5.
We multiplied 1.5 times
120 to get 180.
When we increased x by 1 again,
once again, y increased
by a factor of 1.5.
We multiplied 1.5 times 180.
What I want to do in this video
is to kind of quickly
show you just going from the
basic definition of an
exponential function, why
this is the case.
Why this works for exponential
functions.
So let's just start with a
general exponential, y is
equal to A times r to the x.
And let's look at some x
values and then their
corresponding y values.
These are my x values, those
are my y values over there.
Now let's say that x is equal
to, let me just pick an
arbitrary number.
Let's say that x
is equal to b.
I haven't used that
variable yet.
And what's y going
to be equal to?
It's going to be equal to A
times r to the bth power.
Now, let's increase x by 1.
This would also work if you
increased x by really, just a
constant factor.
But let's increase it by 1.
So we're now going to look at
x is equal to b plus 1.
Then y is going to be equal
to A times r to
the b plus 1 power.
Let's do it one more time.
Let's increase x by 1.
You get b plus 2.
And now Ax-- sorry.
Now y would be A times r
to the b plus 2 power.
Now let's see what happens when
you take the ratio of
each successive y terms that
correspond to the x terms when
you increase by a
constant factor.
And notice, every time we
increased x by exactly 1.
If this was 0, this
was 1, this is 2.
If this is negative 5, this
would be negative 4, this be
negative 3.
So let's see what happens
with our y.
So over here, if we look at the
factor that y changed by,
we could just divide Ar to the
b plus 1 by Ar to the b and
what do we get?
Well you might already recognize
you could use
straight up exponent
rules right here.
The A's cancel out and then this
is going to be equal to r
to the b plus 1 minus b.
Same base.
You're taking the quotient.
You subtract exponents.
So this is just going
to be equal to r.
Let's see what happens when
we go from here to here.
Once again, take the y value
when x is equal to b plus 2,
so Ar to the b plus 2.
Divide it by the previous
y value.
Divide it by Ar to
the b plus 1.
These cancel out and we're left
with r to the b plus 2
minus b plus 1, which is equal
to r to the b plus 2
minus b minus 1.
These cancel out.
2 minus 1.
Once again, you're
just left with r.
So hopefully that satisfies any
curiosity you might have
had of why you're able to use
that as the way to evaluate
whether this data
was exponential.
Why we're able to just say,
hey, let's take this term
divided by the previous term
and see what number we get.
This term divided by that term
and if we get the same number
every time, we're dealing with
an exponential function.